perhaps we can check the camp and locate  your parents  however i noticed the burn on your leg  do you mind if we stop at the medical  tent first to get it looked at  oh i didn't realize my leg was burnt  sure let's go to the doctor first  how are you feeling now mr sanchez  a bit more relaxed thanks for helping me  find my parents earlier  it wasn't easy telling them about the  animals  i'm glad you're feeling a bit more  rested you've been through a lot  it's like a nightmare everyone has lost  so much i can't even begin to imagine  what our lives are going to be like  now it's going to be left of a ranch  i should have checked if i left the  tractor outside  maybe it survived